and the Oscar goes to brouille Brad
[Applause]
Brad including his nomination this year
for original screenplay for Ratatouille
this is the second Academy Award for
Brad
Bird uh I think I'm going to throw up
too um uh I want to thank the academy
and I also want to thank my junior high
guidance counselor uh for a meeting we
had where he asked me what do you want
to do with your life and I said I want
to make movies and he said what else do
you want to do with your life and I said
make movies and he said what if you
couldn't make movies I said I'd have to
find a way that I could what if movies
didn't exist I'd have to invent them and
went on like this till we were sick of
each other and I only realized just
recently that he gave me the perfect
training for the movie
business so uh I want to thank that uh
my my wife Liz who I love um my sons uh
all the dreamers at Pixar and Disney uh
John Lasser Steve Jobs at catmull um
wrap it up hate that thing um uh uh
producer Brad Lewis um Yan pinka and
Dick cook and all the in dreamers um who
are supporting a rat who dreams
thanks